okay before we wrap up and go to
voicemail and a few other things i want
to just follow up on one we told you two
days ago about many of the different
Trump sexual assault accuser stories i
want to just dig into one of those
stories and flesh it out a little more
now that we have more information
yesterday afternoon People magazine
published a story that corroborates
former reporter natasha story not sexual
assault allegations against Donald Trump
stone off spoke out about her sexual
assault after Trump denied that he had
ever groped or kissed any women without
consent stone off is one of 17 women now
who have made some similar claim and she
recounted that she had an interview with
Donald Trump at his Florida Maura Lago
estate and that Donald Trump allegedly
shut the door behind us I turned around
and within seconds he was pushing me
against the wall and forcing his tongue
down my throat Trump reportedly told her
we're going to have an affair I'm
telling you now that at one point was
just Natasha stone offs a story and that
is no reason to dismiss it the fact that
it happened years ago is no reason to
dismiss it but People magazine now has
published not one not two not three not
four and not even five but six different
witness accounts who said at the time
Natasha stone off came to me and here's
the story she told me and not surprising
may be surprising to Donald Trump but
not surprising to many people the six
recollections of what Natasha stone off
said from these six people effectively
exactly the same and this includes her
former journalism professor Paul
McLaughlin who spoke to stone off after
Lee of the alleged event and now is
speaking to people magazine this
includes a friends of stone off what you
might say well the friends are of course
they're going to say whatever it is that
she wants them to say doesn't seem like
there's really much of a need or desire
to insert yourself at this point in this
way if you don't just genuinely remember
being told the story by Natasha stoy not
so now storing off
story is one of only 17 stories of
sexual assault or harassment involving
Republican nominee Donald Trump this
includes 10 women alleging that he had
groped them at some point the media at
this point could come out with a
videotape which has video of Trump
sexually assaulting someone and there
are still going to be people who say add
a video could have been doctored or it
was video but not audio and you just
can't really tell what's going on in
that video uh and and that's just
something that we're going to have to
deal with fewer than three weeks out
from the election at this point I don't
think that the hardcore Trump supporters
at this point are going to carry me the
guy said six months ago I could shoot
people on Fifth Avenue and they'd still
vote for me apparently he could also be
accused of sexual assault by 17 women in
similar scenarios women that don't know
each other over a period of decades and
those same people who wouldn't care
about the shooting on Fifth Avenue are
going to vote for him that we know this
election is going to come down to a few
people in a few key states you have to
look at Florida you have to look at Ohio
you have to look like i said earlier in
the program at the electoral map Trump
has conceded Virginia already he's out
of Virginia a state that often is uh
agent very often read very often blue
Hillary Clinton is ahead by nine in
Virginia and Trump has pulled out of
there those are not good sign so really
whether you have I don't know whatever
percentage you want to say whatever
percentage of Trump supporters do not
care about these allegations they are
ultimately not going to decide the
selection it's going to be the moderate
voters it's going to be these late
undecided voters although I can't
personally understand still being
undecided at this point doesn't really
make sense to me is not something I
understand they actually could make a
difference and it will come down to
states like Ohio and Florida at one
point Trump was saying Pennsylvania was
in play that there's really it's not
looking good uh North Carolina Virginia
it's just that's what it's going to be
determined by and whether it's one two
three four five or six people
corroborating former journalist Natasha
storing off sexual harassment
allegations uh it's it's really not
looking good and will
be in the debate tonight if there's any
headway made on any of this whatsoever